If you are able to figure this out on your own, great. You really don't need to
understand any more about how this works to start developing code and doing more
interesting things when queries come in. But I do want to explain a bit more
about what's going on here. So, the important thing the web application does is
map requests. So, here's the URL that came from the browser, that means the
browser is sending a request to the service running on port 8080 on localhost,
containing this is the request. So, that message will come from the browser. And
this could be a browser running on your own machine if it's a localhost, but it
could be a browser running anywhere in the world. And the request that comes in
will be to get the slash followed by Hummus. That request will come into the
machine and look for the process that's running on port 8080. We don't have a
physical port that corresponds to this, but the operating system keeps track of
what process is running where. And that's the process that started when we
started running that web application. And what happened when that code started
running the web application, is it started listening in on that port so requests
would be directed to this web application. And what the application server will
do is call the GET method of LuckySearch passing in as the query the value
Hummus that came as the query in the GET request. And the key line is this one.
This creates an instance of the application class in the web module and the
first input here, provides a way of mapping requests to the class with a GET
method that will handle that and we'll talk more about that in a second. When
the GET method gets called, it returns the string that goes back through the
application class which adds some extra headers around it to make it work as a
response and that gets sent back to the browser which renders it, as we see
here. So, what is going on with this mysterious input that tells the
web.application how to map request to class. That's what we'll talk about next.